food vlogs episode 15. so i was working
on this fbx model
the one from last episode that looked
really strange and wiry
well as you can see she works fine here
and i have made no changes the only
changes i actually made was i didn't
load all the other models so there's
some sort of conflict probably with a
reused resource that's unintended so i'm
going to have to dig in and figure out
what that is it looks like it has
something to do with the bones or
transformations but those shouldn't be
overlapping as far as i know so maybe
it's something else obscure well
overall though things are looking pretty
good and uh well yeah she scales up
really fast super lady
yeah so if i back up the scale will
actually make a little more sense oh wow
she's going out of render range at that
point
but this the flickering textures yeah
don't worry about it it's just this
shader i think i'm using the actual lit
shader it shouldn't do that at all so
not a huge as big of a deal as it looks
like
i don't think anyway okay but we can
also move her around so naturally once
we we can make her like move forward and
walk with the code when we're actually
doing real
in-game stuff but we have all the
options available here for full
rotations and i have it set in a way
that should avoid most gimbal lock
so feel pretty comfortable with our
spatial stuff all right but yeah i guess
i just really wanted to show here that
the fbx is working actually fine let's
try loading in both models both animated
models and see what happens all right so
i've added back in the code to this guy
and got his own little imue thing for
him so i could get him kind of situated
in a good space to do some little
comparisons and uh well it's pretty
obvious here when we load both of them
the issue shows itself so we've narrowed
it down pretty well just based on that
flip him around
and i know what to look into and this is
why you do beta tests because uh it
looked fine when there was just one
but you don't want to ship that yet you
got to keep working on it anyway that's
where i'm at and we're going to dig in
and figure this out and i believe the
place to start here is by carefully
analyzing these transforms and these
bones i have a feeling it has something
to do with one of those but which and
why that is the question now i
also i'm leaning towards
really examining this model loader and
making sure we're not reusing something
that we shouldn't be reusing since these
are all static functions the only thing
that really gets reused is this last an
empath and that shouldn't be caused an
issue but it could be well let's see
when we do a new load we assign the path
to whatever we're loading so it
shouldn't be passing to the wrong one
for
something like one of these oh maybe
i'm gonna think about this
there's a lot of off the top of my head
stuff i say in these episodes that ends
up not really being correct but it's
just sort of my debugging process and if
i keep going with this that's probably
what it's going to end up as and while
some of you like that majority of people
want to see edited content just want to
see the answer right away and i get that
so i'm going to pause right here and
come back with the results still
debugging and working on things but i
had to get this captured because this is
just amazing just look at the guy on the
left okay so what is happening here is
the last model animated model that i
load that seems to be the one overriding
the stuff before it
or something like that it's very weird
but i almost want to save this
configuration just to do that weird
effect on the left at some point because
that's pretty amazing that could make
for a good i don't know
something creepy
well anyway that does help me narrow
down the problem but i just had to
capture this moment five days later at
least
all right i'm giving up on
whatever the problem is with animations
right now
now that being said it's not that they
don't work there are just some issues
that i can't figure out and i have a
feeling that one day it's going to click
but i've looked at it and looked at it
and gotten burned out on the problem and
i'm not seeing it
so at this time i've decided i'm just
going to move on but i'll i'll explain
what it is and maybe someone will have
some wonderful insight that will help
because uh well i could i can tell you
what the problem is i just can't
pinpoint where it's happening
this is doing a build looks like it's
downloading some packages that updated
all right cool that's another thing
about that's great about using the uh
json
or the manifest
this bad boy if the library is update
it's just gonna go get them
well you can specify a version so if you
don't necessarily want it to update it
won't but if you don't it's just going
to keep these all up to date and looks
like it's updating
what is it updating
let's take a look
this is kind of a need to know things
sometimes looks like it is
asim which is open asset
or whatever you know open asset import
library something like that whatever
they call it i should really think about
this stuff before i just pop on here and
start talking but the reality is
sometimes i'm just like all right i need
to do an update let me hit the button
and i just go in with no plan swinging
okay it updated some other stuff too
maybe
yeah wow we had a lot of
a lot of packages rebuilding
so we're going to let it do its thing
and i guess why that's going on i'm
going to talk about the tests so i made
the tests a little bit better they now
work as you would more expect like this
just they're the tests aren't complete
but this does give some framework for
how they should be done in the future so
we have a test method
and we basically do some stuff but in
this doing some stuff we can add some
prompts with imgui
to have the user specify whether it's
okay or not and that's kind of a cool
thing so
in the future if it's a test that is
something happening on the screen and
there's not necessarily a way to get a
true false from it we can prompt the
user to click true or false
or an ok button or something like that
because sometimes we just want to test
if things look right
and
if the math is adding up but they're not
looking right then there's a problem so
you know there's just a lot of scenarios
but yeah being able to
just make a pop-up is really useful when
you're doing a lot of graphical type
tests like does this animation look
alright and then load another one does
this one look okay you can kind of yes
no through
so we're going to have some tests like
that but also i do want to have a set of
fully automated tests too and once we
get these tests a little more well
established the example project will get
deleted or maybe we'll just move it to
its own repo or something that would
probably make more sense because it does
have quite a bit of logic and examples
within it at this point
so the example project has some value
but it's not really part of the library
it doesn't add anything to the
functionality of what ancient archer as
a
pseudo game engine or whatever you want
to call it is
speaking of that's another thing what do
you call this
now this is most similar to something
called raylive
which
i've never actually really used ray live
but ray live is a well-known
simple and easy to use library to enjoy
video games programming this is
basically what ancient archer is aiming
to be not on purpose i i literally did
not know about ray light when i started
making my engine but if i were to start
over i would just not make my engine
like i talked about in my don't make a
game engine talk and i would just learn
ray live and get really good at it
because i wouldn't be sitting here stuck
on all these backend problems all the
time and i would just be able to make my
game
and
yeah realize i need to do a video on
raylive and so maybe i will learn it
properly at some point
but that doesn't change the fact that
now that i've got you know my whole
engine project going it's not like it's
going to go anywhere other than forward
right
so i might as well keep it up to some
extent even if i do put it on the back
burner sometimes so i'm curious how do
you guys handle stuff like that where
you're working on a project and you find
out later that it's
not really needed sort of obsolete but
you really like the project and you're
having fun working on it and it's a cool
thing that or if maybe a fun thing to
hack on when you're bored and don't have
anything else so yeah maybe let me see
if i can get this going on my own kind
of thing so that's what this ancient
archer is if it becomes something real
at some point awesome it is very real to
me i do plan on making a game with it
and uh
still kind of working up to that but
we're getting closer and closer with
every update so please
while we're sitting here building
packages still go to the github for
ancient archer and give it a star one
star equals one vlog i think we're at 14
at the time of this recording so we'll
see what we get up to and how many vlogs
i'm going to owe you guys
because
i do every video that i owe
now i did say that i was going to show
you where i think the issue with the
animations
is and i will but this is still building
so
give me a minute all right well i was
checking out ray live and it looks like
they have some games
and i clicked on this one
and like
what i'm blown away by how
look just watch okay what do we got here
let's analyze a little okay
wall of seasons press to play alpha
version okay three two what's happening
what's playing what
life killed you
[Music]
what is this game
[Music]
this is so bad it doesn't even seem real
like
what are you talking like how do you
even play what are you talking
you can't just do this in a game
all right ray live not looking so good
anymore okay i'm gonna say that i'm not
aiming for a ray light this this is
awful already like what the heck i know
that this is the developer's fault but
with that buggy sound like
how do you make a game that
you you don't put up games that are that
bad okay just
do you have any idea how many games i've
made i've i've made so many games you
know how many of them i put out none
and some of them i would say were
objectively better than that koala game
oh my thing's finally launching okay
we're getting out of real life needless
to say initial impression really live
not good over here not good i don't mean
to bash i'll try it on my own sometime
and make my own true opinion but all
right so here we go yeah guy guy
animates he walks it's fine but
the problem comes in when i add more
than one animated model if i add another
guy
another animation the issues start
happening where they're all buggy like
we were seeing at the beginning
and as far as i can tell
they are sharing the animation and i
don't know why because i've looked at it
they're different animations they've got
different addresses they're different
instantiations but they all seem to be
like linking together so like the wrong
animations are playing on the wrong
bones and models and that seems to be
the issue but if i just load a single
one it's fine so we're gonna leave it
like this for now until i find the issue
because i looked for it i debugged i
determined that it was fine
and i couldn't figure out why i was
having a problem now i realized that
it's going to be something really simple
it's probably one line of code somewhere
just one little thing one wrong share
one thing that's copying a pointer or
something like that when it's not
supposed to be so i have some ideas what
to try but i haven't
entirely solved but this has been taking
too long i'm going to leave what i got
in there i put it under the testing
so let me just find this
so when you add an animation prop it
does say testing you should be aware
that these aren't going to work right to
but it will improve them and get it out
of testing eventually so this is just
how i do my testing space i know it's
not normal usually people have their own
experimental name space i i might do
something like that yeah i haven't
really decided for now i've just been
tacking on testing so that it's very
obvious to the end user that it's a
function for testing
so that's where the animations are
and also they need lighting on them the
shaders need improved and
that's we're going to figure that out
i'm going to work on some in the next
upcoming steps but i'm pretty happy
about it overall
yeah it kind of stinks to not be able to
find out exactly what's going on in the
animations there
with the multiple
files but i dug through i refactored i
dug through more i refactored it's
i'm kind of at my end with it
but uh it's got its own model loader i
still need to make it reuse models
so maybe i'll just add a few notes here
on the fly
you do
add
ref
or
load saving
that's a weird the board anymore
we're using
already
this is going to be tricky because we
have to do this with both
the model info which is this out model
and we need to make sure we set these
animations
when
or at least grab the right animations i
don't know i gotta i gotta change that
setup or understand it a little better i
think that's the crux of the problem
there are some animations
on every
animated model so we just instantiate an
animated prop it comes with
a pointer to an animator and an
animation
so i might need to do these separately
outside of this and link them
that way somehow and i got to think
about that
yeah that's where i'm at there all right
that's going to do it for this one
thanks for watching see you guys next
time keep going mano
hey thanks for watching don't forget to
like and subscribe it really does mean a
lot it lets me know that i should keep
making this kind of content
[Music]
you